Did you know that
4,476 Christians around the world, more
than 12 a day on average, were killed
for faith related reasons in 2024?
Another
4,744 Christians were arrested or
illegally detained. And nearly 8,000
churches and other Christian
institutions were attacked, many
destroyed. Or did you know that overall
the global persecution of Christians has
reached unprecedented levels so that
more than 380 million Christians suffer
high levels of persecution and
discrimination for their faith. These
are all findings and quotes from the
world watch list of 2025 published
earlier this year by the international
human rights organization open doors.
Each year this list ranks the top 50
nations where Christians are mer most
persecuted for their faith. According to
it one in seven Christians around the
world or 14% of all Christians is
persecuted. In Africa that number grows
to one in five meaning 20%. And in Asia,
it's a whopping two in five, meaning 40%
of all Christians are persecuted in that
continent. Now, the list categorizes the
persecution under three levels. Extreme,
very high, and high levels of
persecution. The top 13 of the 50
nations making the list are
characterized by the worst form of
persecution. Extreme. They are one North
Korea, two Somalia, three Yemen, four
Libya, five Sudan, six etra, seven
Nigeria, eight Pakistan and nine Iran,
10 Afghanistan, 11 India, 12 Saudi
Arabia and 13
Myanmar. The form of persecution
experienced in these 13 worst offenders
ranges from assault, rape, imprisonment,
or downright murder for anyone
identified as Christian. Coming in at
number one is North Korea, where quote,
"If your Christian faith is discovered
in North Korea, you could be killed on
the spot. If you aren't killed, you will
be deported to a labor camp and treated
as a political criminal. You will be
punished with years of hard labor that
few survive. North Korean authorities
are likely to round up your extended
family and punish them, too. Even if
your family members aren't Christians,
there is no church life in North Korea.
It's impossible to gather for worship or
prayer and even secret worship and
prayer is at great risk. Moving down the
list, it's interesting to note that the
extreme persecution meed out to
Christians in nine of the remaining 12
worst nations is a product of what the
list calls Islamic oppression or it
occurs in nations with large Muslim
populations. Put to number, this means
that about 70% of the absolute worst or
extreme persecution around the globe
takes place in the name of Islam.
This trend affects the entire list. The
rest of the very high or high levels of
persecution that Christians experience
in 37 of the 50 ranked nations or 74%.
Also comes either from Islamic
oppression or occurs in nations with
majority or large Muslim populations.
Many of these nations are governed by
some form of Sharia, Islamic law. Those
enforcing the persecution can either be
government or society or more frequently
both. Although societies, particularly
family members outraged by relatives who
have converted to Christianity, tend to
be more zealous in the application of
Sharia. In other words, although North
Korea is home to the worst form of
Christian persecution in the world,
there is at least some light at the end
of the tunnel because the ill treatment
of Christians is entirely connected to
the regime of
Kimyong. Once his line has been ousted,
which is inevitable, North Korea may
well become like South Korea where
Christianity is flourishing. Conversely,
the Muslim persecution of Christians is
existential, perennial, and far
transcends this or that regime or ruler.
It's part of the history, doctrines, and
sociopolitical makeup of Islam. Hence,
its tenacity and ubiquity. Now, let's
take a brief look at those nine Muslim
nations where extreme, the worst form of
persecution occur. In Somalia, which
comes in at number two, where only a few
hundred Christians are believed to
exist, quote, "Following Jesus is a
matter of life and death, El Shabb,"
which means the youth. A violent
Islamist militant group enforces a
strict form of Sharia, Islamic law, and
is committed to eradicating Christianity
from Somalia. They have often killed
Somali Christians on the spot. The
dangers have increased over the years as
the militants have increasingly focused
on finding and eliminating Christian
leaders in Yemen. Number three, the
country is divided into territory ruled
by three different Muslim powers as well
as some areas held by al-Qaeda and the
so-called Islamic State. None of the
powers involved are sympathetic to
Christians. And the official
constitution upholds Sharia, Islamic
law, and no freedom of religion. The 1%
of Yemenes from minority religions are
severely marginalized. Relief aid is
mostly distributed through local Muslim
groups and mosques which are alleged to
be discriminating against anyone not
considered a devout Muslim. If someone
is reported to be a Christian and/or
involved in Christian activities, they
could face severe monitoring, arbitrary
detention, torture, ill treatment, and
even
murder. In Libya, coming in at number
four, quote, "Following Jesus is a huge
risk for anyone. Libyan Christians with
a Muslim background, face violent
pressure from their families and
communities to renounce their faith.
Foreign Christians, especially those
from subsaharan Africa, are t are
targeted by Islamist militant and
criminal groups. These groups kidnap and
sometimes brutally kill Christians. Even
if they avoid such a fate, subsaharan
Christians face harassment and threats
from radical Muslims. Christians who
openly express their faith or try to
share it with others risk arrest and
violent opposition.
in Sudan, which comes in at number five.
Quote, Sudan was on a path towards
religious freedom, but a coup and
devastating war dashed these hopes.
Christians are once again in danger. The
conflict has given Islamist extremists
more opportunity to target them. More
than 100 churches have been damaged so
far, and Christians have been abducted
and killed. Sudin Christians who have
come to faith from a Muslim background
face severe backlash from their families
and communities. in Nigeria. Number
seven, quote, "Jihadist violence
continues to escalate in Nigeria and
Christians are particularly at risk from
targeted attacks by Islamist militants,
including fani fighters, Boo Haram, and
the Islamic State, West Africa province.
The attacks are shockingly brutal. Many
believers are killed, particularly men,
while women are often kidnapped and
targeted for sexual violence. More
believers are killed for their faith in
Nigeria than anywhere else in the
world." Elsewhere, the report notes that
a total of 3,100 Nigerian Christians
quote paid the ultimate price for their
faith end quote in 2024. The report
continues regarding Nigeria. These
militants also destroy homes, churches,
and livelihoods. Christians living in
northern Nigerian states under Sharia,
Islamic law can also face discrimination
and oppression as secondclass citizens.
Converts from Islam often experience
rejection from their own families and
pressure to renounce their new faith.
They often have to flee their homes for
fear of being
killed. Christian carnage is so endemic
to Nigeria that only recently on April
13th, Palm Sunday, 54 Christians were
slaughtered following church
celebrations in one village alone. Since
then, there have been many more
massacres. The headline of an April 22
report is, quote, more than 170
Christians killed during Lent Easter in
Nigeria. And as bad as it is in Nigeria,
according to the report, quote, sadly
more Christians were killed outside
Nigeria. Many in subsaharan Africa,
countries like Democratic Republic of
Congo, Burkina Faso, Cameroon, Niger,
etc. Multiple countries in subsaharan
Africa have seen a rise in violence
against Christians. Currently, eight of
the top 10 deadliest places for
Christians are in subsaharan Africa. And
all of them except Nigeria have more
faith-based killings than they did in
the previous year. Moving along, in
Pakistan, which comes in at number
eight, quote, "Pakistan's notorious
blasphemy laws are often used to target
minority groups, but Christians are
disproportionately affected. Indeed,
roughly a quarter of all blasphemy
accusations target Christians, who make
up just 1.8% 8% of the population.
Blasphemy laws carry a death sentence.
People accused of blasphemy are
vulnerable to attack or murder by mobs.
In June 2024, an elderly man was killed
by mob violence after being accused of
desecrating the Quran. Historical
churches are heavily monitored and have
been targeted for bomb attacks. The
number of Christian girls abducted,
abused, and forcefully converted to
Islam, frequently backed by lower
courts, is growing. All Christians
suffer institutionaliz institutionalized
discrimination. Occupations that are
deemed low, dirty, and degrading, such
as cleaning sewers or working in brick
kils, are reserved for Christians by the
authorities. Many are referred to as
chura, a derogatory term meaning filthy.
Christians are also vulnerable to being
trapped in bonded labor. In Iran, number
nine, quote, unrecognized converts from
Islam to Christianity face severe
religious freedom violations. primarily
from the government and to a lesser
extent from society and their families.
The government views these converts as a
threat, believing they are influenced by
Western countries to undermine Islam and
the regime. Both leaders and ordinary
members of Christian groups are often
arrested, prosecuted, and given long
prison sentences for crimes against
national security. Recognized historical
communities such as Armenian and
Assyrian Christians are state protected,
but treated as secondclass citizens.
They face many discriminatory legal
provisions and are not allowed to
worship in Persian, the language, or
interact with Christian converts. Those
who support converts can also face
imprisonment. In Afghanistan, number 10.
Most Afghan Christians are converts from
Islam, which makes it basically
impossible to practice their faith
openly. In Afghanistan, leaving Islam
and conversion is punishable by death
under Islamic law. This has been
increasingly enforced since the Taliban
took control of the country in 2021. If
converts are discovered, the family,
clan, or tribe may try to preserve its
honor and deal with a convert through
pressure, violence, or even murder. If a
convert's faith is is discovered by the
government, many Afghan believers have
no other option but to try to flee.
Women and ethnic minorities experience
additional oppression. Christians among
these groups live under unthinkable
pressure.
in Saudi Arabia. Number 12, our great
friend and ally, quote, "It's very risky
to become a Christian in Saudi Arabia.
Not only is it illegal to leave the
Islamic faith, new believers will face
intense opposition from their families
and communities as well. Because of
this, most Saudi Christians tend to
follow their faith quietly and secretly.
This extends as far as not even telling
their own spouse or children about their
faith for fear that extended family
members or school staff could discover
that they have left Islam. There are no
legal church buildings or
meetings. So much for the 13 nations,
nine of which are Muslim, where
Christians experience the absolute worst
or most extreme forms of
persecution. Before moving on, it's
interesting to reflect on how different
these nine Muslim nations are, including
racially, socially, economically, and
politically. Some are rich, Saudi
Arabia. Others are dirt poor, Somalia.
Some are advanced, Iran. Others are far
from it, Yemen. They are represented by
a variety of governments. Republics,
monarchies, and one theocracy. Various
different races are represented. Arabs,
black Africans, Pakistanis, Persians,
and Afghans. And they speak a multitude
of languages. These differences grow
even more when looking at the full list
of Muslim nations that make the top 50.
It includes Sinaic or Chinese-like and
Turk nations such as the Maldives,
number 16, Usbekiststan 25, Turkey 45,
and Brune 48. So, what binds all of
these diverse nations together? What
makes them all exhibit the same hostile
behavior against Christians? The answer
should be clear. The one and only common
denominator they all share is Islam. Is
there any more ironclad proof that Islam
is inherently hostile to Christians?
Indeed, to all infidels. That said, and
even though Muslims continue to have a
lion's share of persecution, even
outside the world, hate for and violence
against Christianity has become
pandemic. Quote, "Several countries on
the world watch list saw an increase in
anti-Christian violence. While the
contexts were different, either tightly
controlled autocratic states or
countries that are unstable due to weak
government or civil war, the result was
the same. Targeting of Christian
communities, destruction of lives,
homes, and churches, and immense
pressure on believers. A rise in Hindu
nationalism has made India number 11, a
hotbed of persecution. Quote, "In India,
Hindu extremists view all Christians as
outsiders and aim to cleanse the nation
of Islam and Christianity, often using
extensive violence. This hostility is
often driven by hindata, an ongoing
Hindu nationalist belief among some
extremists that Indians ought to be
Hindu and no other faith will be
tolerated. This mindset has led to
violent attacks across the country and
impunity for the people who perpetrate
them. In such places, Christians who
attend house churches risk attack by
extremist mobs who target services.
Additionally, 12 states have passed
anti-conversion laws which threaten
religious freedom for indiv individual
believers. Even in Buddhist Myanmar,
number 13, the last nation to make the
top 13 offenders where Christians
experience extreme levels of
persecution. Quote, "Since the military
coup in February 2021, Christians have
encountered greater violence and tighter
restrictions. Believers have been killed
and churches have been indiscriminately
attacked. This includes those in
predominantly Christian states. More
Christians than ever have been driven
out of their homes and have found refuge
in churches or displacement camps. Some
are even forced to flee into the jungle
where they're often deprived of access
to food and healthcare. Government
forces have continued to
disproportionately attack Christian
villages and churches. They have also
killed Christian aid workers and
pastors, often in aerial attacks. Beyond
the conflict, converts to Christianity
find themselves persecuted by their
Buddhist, Muslim or tribal families and
communities because they have left their
former faith. Communities who who aim to
stay Buddhist only make life impossible
for Christian families. Indeed, even in
nations that would appear to be friendly
or at least neutral to Christianity, for
example, the predominantly Catholic
nations of Cuba, number 26, Nicaragua,
number 30, Mexico, number 31, and
Colombia, number 46. Christians are
being abused for their faith from a
variety of actors, including drug
cartels, rebel groups, and even the
governments themselves, such as in Cuba
and in Nicaragua. Perhaps the most
disturbing trend is that the persecution
of Christians continues to grow every
year and has nearly doubled since 1993
when the when this list, the World Watch
list, was first issued. Then only 40
nations scored high enough to warrant
sufficient tracking. Today, nearly
double that number qualify, though the
list limits itself to the top 50.
You need to ask yourself, how long
before this ongoing trend spills into
even those western nations once hailed
for their religious liberties, the very
nations you live in? They've already
gotten the Christians of the West to
grow accustomed to being secondclass
citizens in their own nations. How long
before anti-Christian hostility turns
into outright persecution, akin to the
sort we just reviewed? And will the
slowboiled frog of the West even notice
this transition?